[Laughter]
[Music]
beautiful and beloved Mexico Mexico has
just a few months left under the command
of andrees Manuel Lopez orador he is by
far one of the most groundbreaking
political profiles that has passed
through the leadership of the Aztec
state it is time therefore to begin to
evaluate and the first thing to remember
is that the leader of Morena the
national regeneration movement promised
to push for a huge transformation of the
country not surprisingly this this
included a completely new National
Security strategy after all security or
rather the lack of security is one of
Mexico's biggest problems if not the
biggest problem of all Lopez orador
clashes with the Mexican military on his
way to the 2018 presidential election
the politician has for the past month
highlighted human rights violations
committed by the military in the fight
against drug trafficking controversy
over presidential pre-candidate Lopez
oor's proposed amnesty for criminals in
Mexico for the past decade Lopez orador
has criticized the strategy of combating
organized crime through the deployment
of the Army and Navy on the streets
replacing civilian police forces however
in the end it seems that Mexico changed
amlo more than amlo changed Mexico at
least in terms of security amlo
announces an additional 50 billion pesos
for the National Guard amlo will seek to
have the Army and Navy perform permanent
public security tasks to reduce lack of
security the question is in this area is
the Mexico that Lopez orador leaves
behind very different from the one he
was handed in
2018 well the truth is yes but in a very
different way than what we could imagine
and different also from what Amo himself
promised because the truth is that in
recent years The Mexican government has
exponentially expanded the role of the
Armed Forces the military is now in
charge of of a wide range of tasks from
managing internal security to
administering airports Public Works
projects and even state-owned companies
and that has led us at visual politic to
wonder about a few things how on Earth
do you explain that the military gained
so much presence with a President Who
supposedly wanted to demilitarize the
country what caused such a political
turnaround to what extent does amlo
leave Mexico a militarized country well
let's get to
[Applause]
[Music]
work
outside Mexico it is not well known but
the Armed Forces of this country have a
unique history in Latin America they
have all faced the major Western Powers
we are of course talking about the war
between Mexico and the United States
between 1846 and 1848 and also the
French military inter intervention in
Mexico between 1862 and 1867 a conflict
in which both the United Kingdom and
Spain joined the French forces however
by the beginning of the 20th century the
main problems were already internal the
decline of dictator poerio Diaz plunged
the Armed Forces into a chaos of comings
and goings that lasted until the Mexican
Revolution in the 1920s from then on
Mexican uniformed officers served as
faithful Guardians of the Constitution
which for decades was practically
equivalent to being at the orders of the
prri the political party that governed
Mexico uninterruptedly for more than 70
years in any case the important thing is
that this constitutional tradition was
deeply rooted among the uniformed on top
of that during the 20th century Mexico
avoided any militaristic Adventure so
that unlike what happened in Latin
America the Mexican Armed Forces did not
intervene in state affairs that is to
say here there were no katar or generals
who got excited by the idea of imposing
the military boot as a political system
perhaps this explains why the armed
forces have become the most trusted
institution among
Mexicans be that as it may amlo's
government has now taken a 180° turn to
the role of the Armed Forces in state
affairs amlo has put them fully into
areas that until now have been
traditionally civilian we're talking
about Fields as un civilian as these new
military company gets green light to man
Resort in east Las maras amlo will hand
over control of border customs to the
Army Lopez oor's government bought meic
de aason it will be managed by the
military and will have lowcost tickets
now Mexicans are seeing how officers in
the armed forces are suddenly taking
over the management of Tourism companies
telecommunications agencies and even the
control of energy infrastructure this is
what has come to be known as the
militarization of Mexico the presence of
the Armed Forces in government
government and in day-to-day life is
increasing so the question is to what
extent are the uniformed forces
comfortable with this new role how far
does their new influence extend could
the olive green camouflage provoke a
paradigm shift in the Aztec political
system why is amlo betting everything on
an institution that until recently he
rejected well visual politic Community
as always in this video we're going to
answer all these questions let's get on
with
it the war against the
narcos it is no secret Mexico has one
problem above all others drug
trafficking it's a problem so big that
it often overwhelms the conventional
capabilities of the security forces at
least that's what president Philip ceron
thought when he declared war on the
Narcos in
and so beginning in late 2006 The
Mexican government began to
progressively employ military personnel
to support the police in operations
against the cartels gradually military
assistance became more and more common
until it practically became the standard
operation the territories that were
secured remained under military
control at the same time self-defense
groups also known as Community guards
began to be created these groups were
composed of farming families who armed
themselves in order to defend themselves
against the narcos and do you know what
happened next the cartels also began to
arm themselves to the teeth and that was
the beginning of a terrible nightmare 24
young people found shot to death in
Mexico two investigators into the
killing of 72 migrants found dead Mexico
arrests five Zetas for Massacre of 52
people in Mont T Casino Naros murder 11
musicians of a Kumbia band in Mexico the
Narco who ordered the incineration of
the 43 students was arrested in Mexico
and these are just a few examples among
dozens and dozens of different cases
atrocious in the end the drug war ended
in a colossal failure when one cartel
fell another quickly emerged as the
violence multiplied even so neither
Calderon nor his successor Enrique Pano
dared to modify the role of the forces
in internal security on a large scale no
one wanted to show signs of weakness
nobody except for one candidate and
address Manuel Lopez obor who in 2012
said things like
this
and that was not all later in the 2018
campaign amlo intensified and expanded
his criticisms at that time there were
already several cases of abuse of
authority and even extra summary
executions in the framework of the War
on Drugs
emerged and as if that were not enough
Texas Janeiro Garcia Luna who had been
security of public security during the
six-year term of phip Calderon along
with Salvador sien fuos former head of
the Secretariat of National Defense
during the administration of Enrico Pano
were up to their necks in allegations of
corruption bribery collusion with
cartels and moneya laundering the War on
Drugs had come to a dead end and amlo
knew how to make electoral Capital out
of
it Morena the national regeneration
movement swept those 2018 elections
taking just over 53% % of the votes and
not only did It win the presidency but
also the Parliamentary majority for the
ruling Block in other words the
government was completely in amlo's
hands to be able to fulfill his
political program nevertheless with the
Armed Forces he opted for a completely
different
[Music]
path from scolded to
spoiled amlo promised to get the Army
off the streets but as soon as he came
to power he did exactly the opposite
Lopez auor became president of Mexico on
the 1st of December 2018 well during
only his first two years at the Helm of
the Mexican Government he militarized
practically the same amount of functions
as the rest of the governments during
the entire previous decade check it out
most of the tasks and Powers transferred
to the military have to do with the
management of Public Works or the
environment for example recently here on
visual politic we talked about the Mayan
train that was one of the videos be put
together in collaboration with Harvard
International review remember well as we
told you the Mayan train project also
has the military at the helm they are
the ones who are piloting its
construction yet even in spite of this
gamble amlo's government did keep some
of its campaign promises regarding the
armed forces and security at least it
did so for a
Time
nevertheless since amlo's arrival in
power the budget of the Armed Forces has
also skyrocketed although of course this
has a catch because they have also taken
on many more
roles
that is to say its weight in the public
budget has grown significantly even
though the Improvement in the functions
strictly related to the armed forces
have been much more limited but bigger
budget new functions the military are
beginning to be omnipresent in the
Mexican Administration they are
everywhere and the question is why did
amlo change his mind so drastically well
it seems that this was basically the
reason look Amo then laid out his
two-pronged plan to combat both problems
first he said he wants to give the
military more power and authority in
counternarcotics operations because it
is the least corrupt of all Mexico's
agencies and can be the most effective
he noted however that this would require
constitutional reform but he was
convinced he could achieve this in other
words amlo was relying on the military
to be less corrupt and therefore more
effective thus the less things that are
left in the hands of civilians the
better and that's what explains why at
the end of 2022 he announced one of his
most shocking measures Check It Out
Mexican Congress approves National Guard
to pass to military control amidst
criticism what's so special about this
you may ask well the National Guard was
created by amlo himself in 2019 with the
idea that it would be a civilian body
and not a military one it was the way to
get the Army out of Street Security even
so in 2022 he had to backtrack and did
he
ever he ended up handing over his
favorite toy the newly created National
Guard to the military the evolution of
crime and violence was so bad that he
had no other
[Music]
choice in fact this was far from his
only change of heart amlo always
considered the drug war a mistake these
days however he has quite a different
opinion it's okay to change your mind
when you're wrong that's okay we're not
condemning it far from it the problem is
that it's not clear that this strategy
is working either basically it's just
not working we only have to take a look
at the homicide graph to realize that
this is not working well take a look
[Music]
nearly two decades of military
intervention in public security have
failed to end the Relentless violence of
Mexican cartels and have led to
countless atrocities committed by
soldiers and Marines with almost total
impunity today Mexico is not only going
through one of its most violent periods
but also never before have the Armed
Forces played such an important role now
on this occasion Our intention is not to
focus on security what matters to us
here is to see how amlo has entered into
a surprising race to militarize the
country at full speed and that visual
politic Community is something that
brings with it some problems do you want
to know what we're talking about well
let's take a
look the three shadows of Mexican
militarization as a general rule the
militarization of public functions and
competencies that go beyond the military
world does not usually work well
basically because the military has a
very particular specialization although
it is true the case of Mexico is very
unusual corruption violence lack of
trust in civil institutions in any case
the militarization process that Amo is
pushing forward raises some doubts and
problems for example in the first place
The Mexican government is giving the
Armed Forces voluminous budget
allocations to build Public Works manage
airports and to take charge of
advertising campaigns for tourist
Resorts the problem is that this reduces
the capacity to control and audit all
these funds
why well precisely because of this the
ffaa systematically resorts to
classifying and safeguarding the
information of its agencies under the
argument that National Security Public
Safety and National Defense should not
be compromised tracking and evaluating
the use of public resources becomes
extremely complicated this is what we
saw happening with the Maya train more
and more contracts are being assigned to
the military in a rather discretionary
manner with little or no transparency
and without complying with all the legal
requirements of public bidding you know
the argument is always the same National
[Music]
Security secondly the rationale of
establishing military administrations to
reverse corruption in civilian spaces
may end up generating something of a
self-fulfilling prophecy logic if there
are fewer civilians and more military
corruption is likely to fall in the
short term but of course with less
transparency more attributions and less
qualified professionals why wouldn't
corrupt option end up appearing here too
that's the first question second is the
solution going to be to completely
militarize the state this raises doubts
to say the least and third we have what
is perhaps the biggest problem of all
the feared loss of neutrality the
attempt for the delegation to the Armed
Forces to tie the hands of future
governments also implies a greater
partisanship of the armed forces their
Progressive identification with a
specific political project and something
more serious it implies the loss of
neutrality an essential characteristic
for institutions that fulfill State
tasks and that the armed forces in
Mexico have managed to maintain for
decades amlo is turning the military or
at least its top commanders into real
politicians and that could become a
major problem would the military accept
a government that questions their work
wouldn't they have a preference for
political leaders who promise them more
influence power and bigger budgets and
if they are more honest as amlo claims
to manage ports and public works why
wouldn't they be more more honest to
govern the whole country history teaches
us that we have to be concerned about
these
[Music]
things in any case since April of 2023
the Supreme Court has started to
question this unchecked growth of the
military's roles in government for now
the court struggle with amlo does not
have a clear outcome be that as it may
what we can be sure of is that the
militarization of Mexico is no longer a
project but a reality but now the
questions are for you what do you think
about the military taking on more and
more functions do you think it's a good
response to corruption are you for or
against it how else can the serious
problems of corruption crime and drug
trafficking that Mexico is experiencing
be solved after all without them it is
very likely that Mexico would become a
very prosperous country leave us your
answers in the comments if you found
this video interesting please like it
and don't forget to subscribe to visual
politic if you haven't already done so
all the best see you
soon
[Music]